aux etats unis justement où il y a un an
jour pour jour les américains réalisent
et que contrairement aux prévisions des
sondages la victoire de joe biden
n'était pas si acquise que cela il aura
fallu attendre plusieurs jours après le
vote pour connaître le nom du vainqueur
un an après jordan vient en revers
politique en virginie un scrutin
important vu comme un test pour le
président américain
on en parle avec thomas bonnet à
washington ce soir thomas après ces
élections locales désastreuse à forte
valeur symbolique joe biden mais un
petit coup de pression à son parti au
congrès américain
oui c'est une défaite douloureuse pour
joe biden en virginie rendez vous coûte
ne rendez vous compte il ya un an elle
est démocrate avait remporté cet état de
virginie avec dix points d'avancé sur
les républicains mais cette fois ci ils
ont donc perdu malgré les soutiens de
joe biden de kamala harris ou encore de
barack obama qui s'étaient succédé pour
venir justement appuyé la candidature du
candidat démocrate en virginie et bien
tout cela n'aura pas suffi alors le
parti démocrate est un peu en gueule de
bois après ce revers électoral et
cherche maintenant à en tirer les
enseignements écouté par exemple joe
biden qui a été interrogé sur le sujet
à
12.6 getting d'un ce que je sais c'est
que les gens veulent que nous fassions
des choses ils veulent que nous fassions
avancer des choses et c'est pourquoi je
continue à faire pression pour que le
parti démocrate aille de l'avant et
adopte mon projet de loi sur les
infrastructures et mon projet de loi
bild mcb l1
les gens sont bouleversés et incertain à
propos de beaucoup de choses du code
vide à l'école en passant par l'emploi
et toute une série de choses et aussi le
coût de l'essence et donc si je suis en
mesure de signer la loi sur mon
initiative bill bac belles heures je
suis dans une position où vous allez
voir beaucoup de ces choses améliorer
rapidement il faut donc le faire
compte tenu de ce que vous avez dit
assumer vous une certaine responsabilité
et pensez vous que terry mcauliffe
aurait gagné si votre programme avait
été adoptée avant le jour du scrutin hu
et bien je pense que nous aurions dû
adopter avant le jour de l'élection mais
je ne suis pas sûr que je serai en
mesure de changer le nombre de personnes
très conservatrice qui se sont présentés
dans leur district et qui en votait pour
trump mais peut-être peut-être
alors vous avez entendu ce début d
explication de la part du président
américain effectivement l'inaction de
joe biden depuis son arrivée à la maison
blanche est un constat amer puisqu'il
est bloqué vous le savez par le congrès
américain mais en réalité la fracture
est telle que même au sein du parti
démocrate l'analyse de cette défaite à
diffèrent selon les sensibilités les
progressistes rejetant la faute sur les
modérés et les modérés rejetant la faute
sur les progressistes alors malgré les
appels en ce sens de joe biden il n'a
rien n'indique à l'heure actuelle que
cette défaite puisse servir à
d'électrochoc pour accélérer le
calendrier des réformes de joe biden joe
biden qui est jugé très durement par les
américains il ya des sondages et qui
sont parus récemment notamment une
enquête d'opinion menée par nbc où on
voit que les américains la proa
n'approuve pu réellement l'action de joe
biden en tout cas ils sont une minorité
maintenant aux états unis et puis
l'autre symptôme de ce désamour envers
le président des états unis c'est
l'élection dans le new-jersey où tout le
monde annonçait une victoire large et
facile des démocrates et finalement le
scrutin s'est avéré bien plus serré que
prévu même si les démocrates l'ont
finalement emporté